[Music]
what is he doing
i'll explain to you what is he doing
they're incentivizing people to get the
vaccine in new york city
free fries when you get vaccinated um
i got vaccinated
you're saying i could get this your
delicious
is this fries at this point oh no this
is so nice
are you trying to bribe me with french
fries yes
house how stupid do they really really
think people are this stupid ah oh
[ __ ] do you think that people have just
been holding out for some french fries
oh you think you're just getting french
fries no no finish watching
free fries when you get vaccinated um
i got vaccinated
you're saying i could get this the
delicious fries
why am i but there's also a burger
element to this
let me let me check with bill needhart
is it too early in the day to eat a
birthday
no this could be breakfast okay
i want you to look at this and think
about
again some people love hamburgers the
government
[ __ ] with us at this point
and the problem is is if you talk about
the how [ __ ] these people are you'll
go to probably go to jail
you want to respect all do i get a soda
too though if this is appealing to you
just think of it no bloomberg made a
soda's illegal so
oh yeah and the fries are disgusting
because they don't use transformations
they're not allowed to use trans fats or
any oils so yeah no
i don't want your disgusting burger and
also um
free by new york city standards which
means for some reason the fries still
costs 15
so this is the selling point i'm gonna
do it with you mike so let's do this hey
mike you want to rewrite your dna
not real i mean unless it's like to get
superpowers no no just randomly we don't
know what's going to happen you can get
sick you want to rewrite your dna
i get sick anyway i just usually get
sick and then i'm fine i don't know so
no okay
but what if i give you a burger what
kind of burger
jeez what i mean what from what place
oh shake shack no
you [ __ ] kidding me get out of my
face ways of life but
five guys maybe you know it's appealing
to you just think of this when you think
of vaccination
oh my did you see okay i didn't i didn't
get this deep into this why are they
making it look like an infomercial like
you're not even making it not look like
an
infomercial this is appealing to you
just think of this when you listen to
the vaccination
you didn't even taste it yet
but do you notice that yeah do you
notice he um before it even touched his
mouth
these people are not human beings
right like if if you wanted to write
some kind of a pa like a satirical movie
about aliens disguising themselves as
humans and like
running the planet that would be a scene
in the movie
like he literally went um
dude can i see that again i have to see
it again i'm sorry
no please here you go it's watch guys
watch how he moves before he even tastes
the burger it's the funniest [ __ ] ever
when you think of vaccination
you see what i mean though he doesn't
even it doesn't even get near his taste
buds and he's like hmm
this is this is remember when dave
vaccinated
and get free burgers by the way you know
you know what's funny is that
i always say this this is what they
think of you and you know what's you
know what's funny this is gonna work on
some people some people are the stupid
but they think all of you are this
stupid
all of you are just this dumb it feels
like
aliens yeah it really does like if you
said to me
this guy is an alien that just became
mayor of new york and we had to
he has to keep up his people persona i
none of this seems real right
this feels like a sketch free shake
shack get a voucher for a burger or
sandwich if you get your shot at nyc
mobile vaccine clinic
get free fries with a burger or sandwich
if you show proof of vaccination now
remember shake shack's not doing this
out of the goodness of their heart the
city is paying shake shack of course
burgers
so they're not really free you're paying
the ho some of the people they're still
paying for the second highest taxes in
the country
you're paying for them to get a
experimental vaccine and a free shake
shack burger
vaccination
vaccination um
it's again it's like they're not here
it's
we really have become this society where
like
the powers that be have become
they're really like they're the
principal skinner
there's a really dorky like hey quiet
down in the back there
okay i'll don't make me write you up
they're becoming that guy like and and
the whole world is just becoming these
kids that are just
throwing paper airplanes and being like
this is
just ratioing everything they're losing
control over people and they're not
happy
and it's fun to watch like it is
it's fun to watch a guy like bill de
blasio living in his own self-created
hell
like that that you have to like i know
that people go what do you talk he's the
mayor of new york and he's
you know he's rich liberal elite he's
got he does not have a good life his
daughter is a mess
his life's a mess his personal life's a
mess and no human being can go on
television and go mmm
vaccination french fries and and feel
good
like he doesn't feel good about himself
at least take some comfort in knowing
that he did this and when i don't feel
good his daughter looks like a cyberpunk
glitch
like she's really [ __ ] looking man
oh [ __ ] i'm getting a very good feeling
about vaccination right this moment what
why are you talking with your mouth open
and eating with your mouth open excuse
me